this video is sponsored by longevity
technology
so hello and welcome to the cheeky
science show where in this video we're
going to talk
all about certain six and why it's
called the longevity saturn
so first we'll introduce the basics or
setones where you can find them in a
cell
and what their cellular activities are
and then we'll look at
a series of studies that have shown a
link between seton sex
activity and lifespan in different
muscle organisms
and then that will nicely lead us on to
looking at sir two and six
activators and why there's currently a
lot of interest
around finding molecules that can
activate so two insects
and so we'll discuss that at the end of
the video
but firstly what are sartunes well
said twins are considered a family
because in mammals
including us we have seven different
setuans
which are conveniently called seton 1 to
ce2 and 7.
and the reason that they are a family is
because these proteins
all share an enzymatic domain but they
have different tears at either end of
their protein sequence
that recruits them to different parts of
a cell and influences
what other proteins and molecules they
interact with and so the different
setuans are structurally related
but they can perform different functions
within a cell
although for some of them that
activities do overlap slightly
so what are their activities well
saturants are nad plus dependent enzymes
so what that means is that their
enzymatic activity
depends on the availability of nad plus
standing for nicotinamide adenine
dinucleotide
and nad plaster is a really important
cofactor that's found within cells
so with the availability of nad plus
so two wins can carry out protein
deathelation
which is the removal of acell groups
from different proteins
and they also possess mono adp ribosomal
transferase activities
and so you don't really have to
understand what either of that means but
basically they have the ability to
modify what marks are present on
different proteins
and by modifying these marks it can
affect the stability localization and
activity of a variety of different
proteins and so this is why the
different setuans vary because due to
their different structural differences
they interact with different proteins
and this is also influenced by their
cellular localization
as they'll only be able to interact with
proteins that are localized in the same
area
and so out of the seven saturants so two
in one
six and seven are primarily found within
the nucleus of the cell so where the dna
is found
whilst so two and three four and five
are found in the mitochondria
and so two and two is mainly in the
cytoplasm
and so even though sed2n1 and 6 are both
found in the nucleus
they're not tripping over each other's
toes because they have different binding
affinities to different proteins
and the reason i pick on said two in one
answer two and six
is because this helps to segue into
looking at longevity research
in connection with certains because if
we go back to 1999
when a study came out that showed that
yeast lifespan was extended by 30
when it had an extra copy of a gene
known as cer2
and this was thought to be achieved by
stabilizing the yeast genome
hinting at its activity being localized
in the nucleus
and so if you didn't guess by the name
the yeast sir2
is a homologue of the mammalian saturns
and so that raised the question of
well what would happen if you had
additional copies
of mammalian saturants well studies have
been done to investigate this
and one thing that's worth mentioning is
that it's a two and one and so two and
six
protein levels have been shown to
increase upon dietary restriction
and fasting in various mouse tissues and
human cell lines
with dietary restriction still being one
of the
most consistently seen interventions
that can extend
lifespan in a variety of different
muscle organisms
but more interestingly mouse models have
been made whereby they can actually
overexpress different settlements and so
when there was whole body
certain one over expression of mice they
found that it improved several
parameters reflecting health span
but it didn't seem to extend lifespan
however other studies have shown that
over-expression of cert one just in the
brain of mice
did show a lifespan increase and there's
still interest surrounding
so 2n1 activators such as resveratrol
pterostilbene and other tattooing
activating compounds known as stacks
that do share benefits to enhancing
certain one activity
but i said in this video we're going to
talk about said two and six
so what happens if you have additional
setup and six
well that's been done in mice as well
and a nature paper that came out in 2012
showed that over expression of said two
and six in mice
and so this is whole body
over-expression it was found to extend
the male lifespan
but not the female lifespan and in this
early study they also found that the
male mice that had over-expression or
cert-1
had reduced levels of igf-1 and so igf-1
is a major growth factor
responsible for stimulating growth in
different cell types
anyway differences weren't seen in the
females and whilst to some extent it's
thought that
females have lower levels of igf-1
compared to males
they also found a lot of differences in
liver gene expression between male and
female mice
anyway despite the sex-dependent
differences observed in this study
a paper that came out earlier this year
has shown that cert
six over-expression in a different mouse
strain did extend lifespan in both males
and females
and you can see that in this figure here
whereby it led to an extension in median
lifespan
of 27 in the males and 15 in the females
and you can also see in a study that
they also had over expression of cert 1
which in cooperation with the earlier
study
was shown here to not extend the
lifespan of the mice
and further support from that comes from
the fact that when you over express
both said two and six and so two in one
there isn't any enhanced benefits
and that it overlaps with said two and
six over expression alone
but the curious thing is why in this
paper they did see a lifespan extension
in the females whilst the previous study
didn't
well one explanation that the authors
give is that this time they did see a
reduction in the igf-1 levels
in the females at old age when they were
over expressing
certain sex which in the previous study
they didn't see any change
however two and six over expression had
a milder effect in the females in a
variety of other
parameters that were looked at in this
more recent paper
for example the treadmill endurance
benefits
and changes in the liver transcriptional
profile
showed milder changes in the females
than the males as if we put the
information from both studies together
it does suggest that
the female benefit is less than in the
males but why that is the case still
does seem a little bit unclear
but it emphasizes as well how important
it is to repeat studies in different
mouse models because evidently things
can vary
and this is one of the reasons why
translating data from
mice to humans is also such a challenge
now the other interesting thing to
mention about this paper is that they
showed that so two and six over
expression
helped to restore energy homeostasis and
to some extent that isn't surprising
because
sotoman activity is dependent on nat
plus
and nad plus is often referred to as a
metabolic sensor
the abundance of nad plus varies
depending on the energy status of a cell
i say what they show in this paper is
that in the mice that had over
expression of cert two and six
they found that there was increased
mitochondrial biogenesis and a liver
and this was correlated with higher
expression of the gene pgc1 alpha
which regulates the expression of genes
involved in mitochondrial biogenesis
i realize this isn't the clearest of
figures but the green bars show mice
overexpressing ce2 and 6 and the blue
shade the control mice
with the first two bars being young mice
and the last two bars being old mice
and so you can see that there's an
increase between the old saturn
overexpressing and
and the old control mice and so this
work fits in nicely with the previous
studies
showing that certain 6 levels increase
under fasting
but saturn 6 doesn't just seem to be
involved in metabolism
it also plays a critical role in the
response to dna damage
and interestingly a very nice study came
out that found a positive correlation
between certain six ability to repair
dna
and lifespan in different rodents
whereby rodents that live longer
seem to have more efficient settling six
enzymes
that can repair dna damage and so these
different rodent species have slight
variations in their so two and six
protein
sequence and that causes differences in
saturation
activity and what they seem to suggest
that that is that that could be
contributing to the differences seen in
their maximal lifespan
now one of the things that i thought was
quite interesting about this paper
is that when they compared the activity
of the the mouse certain insects and the
beavers are two and six
so the mouse being weaker than the
beaver which corresponds with the
beavers having a longer lifespan than
the mice
was that there was a much stronger
increase in the beavers set two and six
activity
of mono ribosylation as opposed to
the protein theotolation suggesting that
this monoadp rhoboscillation activity
is more strongly involved in the dna
repair function of certain six
and the reason i thought it'd be
interesting to mention that is because
this brings us on to the last point
which is
other ways of actually being able to
activate so 2 and 6
without having to over express the gene
now
activators tend to be less common than
inhibitors of
enzyme activity and that's partly
because for an inhibitor the rationale
is that you just have to block
the binding site of the substrate which
and without getting too biochemical
is easier to do based on structural
models than to find activators
besides the point there has actually
been some studies that have found
so called allosteric activators or so
two and six
and so allosteric refers to the fact
that these compounds
are binding to settle insects in a
different location
to where the substrate would bind and so
by binding elsewhere it can alter the
conformation of the protein and
hopefully activate the protein
and so in this study they identified the
compound
mdl 800 that could activate saturn vi
dtelation by increasing the binding
affinity
of soto insects to acetate substrates
now the interesting thing with this
study is that we actually have some in
vivo data in mice
whereby injection of mdl 800 to the mice
reduced tumor growth in a cenographed
model whereas
all other proposed set 2 and 6
activators so far have only been
examined in vitro
and more on from that no saturn 6
activator so far has been
shown to have any connection with
lifespan extension or health spine
extension
but going back to what i was saying
about the diacetylation activity
versus the mono adp ribosylation
activity
is that this mdl800 seems to only
activate the acetylation activity
not the adp ribosylation activity and so
based on the work from the other study
showing that the adp robustlation
activity
might be more important for dna repair
it would therefore be interesting to
find compounds
that might preferentially outer fade
this adp-ribosylation
activity but um besides me getting a two
biochemical again
what can we conclude from this video
well saturn 6 is
evidently involved in a variety of
different cellular processes
and that's partly due to the fact that
it can influence the activity
of many different proteins the
involvement of seton 6
and the repair of dna damage seems like
one of the more important functions
especially tied with its longevity
connection
but it can't be avoided that psyton sets
can also influence metabolism within a
cell
it will be interesting to see if saturn
6 activators can be identified
and more on from that shown to have
benefits in health span and lifespan
but this would require in-five models
probably than in mice
to really evaluate the efficacy it would
also be interesting to see how the
certain six activators
might work in combination with
mechanisms of increasing
nad plus levels since saturn 6 evidently
needs nad plus
and so it is likely that they would
synergize together
but i think it's clear from the work so
far that tattoo and 6 can be considered
the longevity settlement
given the lifespan extension seen in
these mouse models when they overexpress
a two and six
albeit the sex dependent differences are
definitely very interesting
and the identification of safe and
tolerable
compounds that can activate saturn sex
would definitely be exciting
in terms of its potential to delay the
onset
of different age-related diseases or
even aging itself
so with that i'd like to thank the
sponsor for this week's video
longevity technology for which i'm very
grateful longevity technology delivers
high quality daily news and insights on
research
investments and technologies that extend
health span and lifespan
find the link to their website in the
description so i hope you've learned
something in this video
and learned a lot more about certain sex
without me getting too biochemical
but um i can't help it so thank you to
my patreon supporters
and thank you for listening